The clouds between the
stars of the galaxy are
made of everything that
the earth, your body and
your car is made of.
There's everything that
you need floating in
gaseous form between the
stars.
4.5 billion years ago.
The gas and dust
collapse once more.
It ignites explosively
to create a new star.
Our Sun.
Close to the young son.
All of the lighter stuff
got blown away.
What was left behind was
the heavier, denser
stuff. There was carbon,
there was iron, there was
gold, everything in
between.
Over time, these free
floating elements begin
to coalesce.
Dust becomes rock.
Rocks joined to form
larger objects called
Planetesimals. Finally,
Planetesimals joined to
form the Earth.